on a crisp afternoon in march a smart
young russian woman
touches down in london on a flight from
moscow
yulia skripal makes this journey often
to visit her father
in the historic city of salisbury but
this is no ordinary family
and no ordinary family reunion
julia's father 66 year old sergey
skripal
is a former double agent a colonel in
russia's military intelligence agency
the gru
he's believed to have been turned by mi6
in the 1990s to spy for the uk
it was a high-stakes move and moscow
eventually found out
the veteran officer was jailed in russia
for 13 years
but partway through his sentence in 2010
he was freed
and transferred to the uk in a cold
war-style spy swap
that should have been the end of the
story thanks to an
unwritten rule between spies that
guarantees their safety in an exchange
but this code is about to be broken on
the 4th of march 2018
the day after 33 year old yulia arrived
in salisbury
two would-be assassins close in on
sergey skripal's house
armed with a deadly nerve agent they
spray the substance on the front door
handle and leave
it's only a matter of time until the
father and daughter
are unwittingly exposed to the poison
they fall critically ill victims of an
apparent revenge attack
blamed on russia's gru good evening this
is sky news live
in salisbury the center of a major spy
attempted murder investigation
having established that a nerve agent is
the cause of the symptoms
leading us to treat this as attempted
murder i can also confirm that we
believe the two people originally who
became unwell
were targeted specifically the
government has concluded
that it is highly likely that russia was
responsible for the act against sergey
and julia skripal
people around the world are familiar
with the salisbury spy poisoning
but this attack involves much more than
just the act of leaving
a military-grade nerve agent soon after
the first news breaks of the attempted
double murder
russian media outlets begin pumping out
alternative versions of what might have
happened
[Music]
russia linked social media accounts also
go into overdrive
they make claims like could the spy
agency mi6 have done it
what about the top secret british
defense laboratory portend down
maybe it was involved the barrage of
dubious claims
seems deliberately designed to create
doubt to play on the allure
of conspiracy over evidence-based fact
it leaves the uk facing the double
challenge
of having to deal with the first
chemical weapons attack
on european soil since the second world
war
while at the same time combating a
global web of disinformation
aimed at discrediting british
accusations that russia was to blame
welcome to 21st century warfare
and welcome into the gray zone
[Music]
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
in this episode i travel to salisbury
with the widow of former russian spy
alexander lipvinenko
to revisit the attempted assassination
of another
ex-russian agent on british soil
but first what exactly is the gray zone
[Music]
we're neither in a state of peace nor
are we in a state of war
but we're sitting in this very dangerous
place
between lieutenant general graham lamb
is a former director of uk
special forces and a master of
unconventional warfare
winston churchill his famous book one of
his
recollection of the second world war was
the gathering storm
there never was a war in all history
easier to prevent by
timely action than the one which has
just
desolated such great areas of the globe
it could have been prevented in my
belief without the firing of a single
shot
but no one would listen we were all
sucked into
that awful whirlpool general lamb knows
his military history
but he also knows about modern threats
and thinks churchill's observation
carries a new relevance today this is
not
a case of a cold war against china this
is not a new cold war against russia
this is the 1930s
and so if we don't recognize that we're
in that period probably about 1930
31 32 33 that we are
actually in a gathering storm and if we
do
as we did in that time merely
try and accept that others would act
in our best interests when they
absolutely by design
did not intend to then don't be
surprised if we end up in 1939
and a world war which nearly killed this
country and would have changed the
global
order as we know it graham lamb isn't
someone who issues idol warnings
i first met him in iraq in 2007 when he
was deputy commander
of all u.s led forces based out there
following the invasion to topple saddam
hussein
general lam has since left the military
but he's still an
expert on the world's security threats
in particular
a murky grey zone of harm that
deliberately sits
under the threshold of what would
normally be described as war
though in many ways this gray zone is no
less dangerous than a real conflict zone
and it affects all of us i find the
terms war
and peace absolutely irrelevant
everybody assumes we're in a peaceful
state nothing could be further from the
truth
we're in a warlike state but not war as
we would look at it from
you know the netflix battle of midway or
pearl harbor or something like this
we're not
in this titanic struggle between the
sort of the wehrmacht and montgomery on
the
um in north africa uh at alamein but we
are being
attacked we're being undone in a very
different way
when you think of war you probably
imagine things like
tanks troops explosions death but if you
fell out with a state
that had a more powerful military than
yours or if you wanted to avoid the cost
of a full-on armed conflict you'd
probably try to think of other ways to
win an argument
that's where the gray zone comes in
it's a place where there are no rules
and literally anything can be
and is used as a weapon
think about the information you absorb
the politicians you elect
even the technology you use just imagine
the power you'd have
if you were able to make people think a
certain way
or vote for a certain party or control
their mobile phone
laptop or car you could change the fate
of a nation
without needing to put a boot on the
ground
so thank you ever so much for speaking
to me for this
grayzone podcast i'm sitting socially
distance in a room in london
with general sir nick carter the head of
the uk's armed forces
and ben wallace the defense secretary
you say we aren't in a state of peace
and we're not in a state of war
what are we in contest we're competed
against
every day some people compete within the
rules and some people
compete outside the norms or the rules
that we've all got used to
that's ben wallace every day we
see our adversaries using cyber tools
against us
using disinformation into our society
in in some areas using financial
corruption using organized crime
to divide us to weaken us
or to compete with us i ask him and
general carter
what the risk is if we don't recognize
and do something
about this often invisible threat the
military chief responds first
so on the one hand we might wake up one
day and discover that we are in a police
state
and all of our freedoms have been denied
us that's one end of it
the other end of it is that our
opponents will have found a way to
unravel our democracy from inside and
our
freedom our way of life and all the
things that we aspires
would have been undermined and we won't
have noticed it without a shot being
fired
that that successful gray zone warfare
from
adversaries is that they know that
if they can do all of those things they
might not have to commit
a gun or a tank or anything and they
would have done it
using proxies done it through cyber done
it through crippling
economy and then if you did want to
drive in one day with your armor brigade
there's not much left to get in the way
general carter says the gray zone could
also spark a full-on
armed conflict what is the biggest
threat in the gray zone
miscalculation because what you're
having here is
a significant amount of activity which
is below the threshold
of what we would call war but the risk
of that activity
being misunderstood or indeed escalation
occurring as a consequence of it
that ends up lighting a fuse is the
thing that is most worrying
and of course if you look back over
history it's those moments of
miscalculation which often precipitate
what ends up being an uncontrollable
state of war
and that's the bit that we really really
have to watch the whole concept
of what warfare can be and therefore
what the threat looks like
is changing try to think of the gray
zone as a global battlefield
the front line is everywhere and no one
is too unimportant to be a target
opposing sides are blurred with
governments big business
and criminal gangs all using the same
kind of tactics
to attack each other and everyone else
the weapons of choice include
deliberately crafted lies spread online
cyber hacks and bribes but the gray zone
has many physical dimensions
too at the sharp end there are
assassinations
to eliminate someone who perhaps poses a
threat
or is causing a problem there's also
energy
countries with oil and gas could use it
to pressure nations that rely on their
power
to act a certain way or perhaps turn a
blind eye to a certain wrong
gray's own warfare touches corporations
too
imagine you're a small firm
manufacturing a clever piece of
technology
that's used by a larger company which
say
happens to be building sensitive
military equipment for the uk government
a chinese firm wants to buy you for a
decent price
and you accept but what then if
relations between the uk
and china become fraught a way for
beijing to harm london
could be to use this chinese-owned
british
company to sabotage the kit with faulty
technology
or technology that includes spyware
which is able to look at what the
british government is doing
when you start to think about all the
different ways to hurt another nation
short of war the gray zone options are
literally endless
back to graham lamb if you were the
ruler of a rogue state
and you had all the levers of power at
your disposal what would you
how would you go about undoing a
democracy
you don't just go against the military
you don't just stand up with
the equivalent of 12 carrier groups like
the america's got
or an opposite number to an f-35 strike
fighter
what you do is you work on all the other
things which is this gray zone you the
the sort of what i call
hybrid the sort of the warfare people
can't find the word for but it's all
this other stuff
where you're operating by design through
diplomatic channels through intelligence
sounds through information the media
through in fact political channels
through economic channels
where you're undoing confidence in an
economy
in the gray zone the whole point is to
cause harm to your enemy and gain an
advantage
without them feeling sufficiently
threatened or realizing they're under
attack
you know there's the old that great
maxim that says you know you want to
boil a frog
you don't drop it into boiling water
because it'll jump straight out again
you put it in cold water and you slowly
bring the water up to boil
in doing so by the time the frog
realizes it's getting too hot
it's lost the energy to be able to jump
out we're being
boiled like a frog security is something
most people
in western democracies take for granted
they probably don't worry about dying in
a bomb blast or a gunfight when stepping
outside their front door
food is almost always in the shops
petrol is in the pumps
and power is pretty much guaranteed to
flow through your home with the flick of
a switch
the coronavirus pandemic has corrected
this complacency a little
but people still generally expect to
live securely
though perhaps now with a stockpile of
toilet roll in western democracies
there's also the protection of the rule
of law the freedom to speak
and governance by democratically elected
and accountable politicians
but these aren't divine rights if people
fail to protect them
they will falter especially when those
operating in the gray zone
choose to exploit a society's
vulnerabilities people are coming here
to
kill our people they are absolutely
killing
our way of life because they're bringing
doubt misinformation
all the sort of normal stuff you see in
the cyber world and all the rest
they bring in this constant message
of we're not good enough we're not fit
for you know
divide and rule so you separate the
parts of britain you separate the
individuals within the country
and suddenly in fact now they're
malleable so these things are absolutely
under attack
by others who wish to gain an advantage
whether it's a criminal
whether it's a proxy whether it's a
militia whether it's a rogue nation
whether it's in fact a functioning state
which sits down and uses its veto or
uses its own authority its own
capabilities
which are in the cyber world significant
to therefore in fact what i call
undo world order it's what's happening
now as you listen to this podcast
and it's why understanding the threat is
so important
our journey begins in salisbury the site
of one of the most high profile gray
zone attacks on the uk
the attempted assassination of sergey
and yulia skripal
and the fake news that followed
you can play a game how to get
salisbury oh in russia in russia yes
what is it
it is a board game it's a board game yes
it's
with all rules with a skripal house
and everything it's just like a monopoly
board
monopoly it's just you uh it's a more
like
litter you know a snake and little
snakes and ladders yes
to find your way to salisbury cathedral
yes i'm with a woman whose
own life was turned upside down by
suspected russian assassins
marina lipvinenko's late husband
alexander
or sasha was also a former russian spy
living in the uk
he too was viewed as a traitor by the
kremlin having become
an increasingly vocal critic of
president vladimir putin
after he started a new life in the uk
with british citizenship
moscow is accused of dispatching two
hitmen to kill
him their weapon was a radioactive
poison polonium-210
they slipped it into his green tea after
inviting him to a meeting
at the millennium hotel in london's
mayfair
in november 2006
he took more than three agonizing weeks
to die
the poisoning was described as a nuclear
attack on the streets of london
and london held moscow responsible
her past means marina feels a close
attachment
with the events of the 4th of march 2018
in salisbury
order taking to assassinate people
is not taking just day before and
unfortunately is not half
how to say about it you know like
sometimes you're watching movie
mission about it at the in the last
minute no when it made it order it never
aborted
just one day it happened it's the same
as the kripal when he was exchanged
but for putin it was always he is a
betrayer
and for the traitor it's only this two
officers from russia's gru
military intelligence agency allegedly
travelled to salisbury by train from
london
armed with a liquid nerve agent such
substances
attack a body's nervous system and are
banned under international law
the choice of a chemical weapon for the
attack is part of the gray zone message
being sent not just to sergey who as i
mentioned at the start was a former
colonel in the gru
but to anyone else deemed to have
betrayed russia
it was also a warning to the uk the
country that turned him
the particular nerve agent used was from
a group called novichok
first developed by the former soviet
union
the would-be assassins walked to the
scripple house from the station
and sprayed the poison contained in a
perfume bottle
onto the front door they then returned
to london
flying out of the country later that day
marina and i
retraced their steps to sergey's
semi-detached property
i have a feeling it's that house there
without the cars in front of
they're not guys i think it's the left
one you know why it's a new roof
sergey came to the uk in 2010 following
a spy swap
that saw him and three other russian
prisoners
exchanged in vienna for 10 alleged
undercover russian agents who'd been
arrested by the fbi
in the united states salisbury was an
obvious place for him to settle
as it was also where his former mi6
handler
apparently lived but eight years later
sergey's government-funded home had to
be completely decontaminated
and a new roof fitted after he and his
daughter were poisoned
he's never returned and by the look of
the lifeless windows
no one else has raced to move in
so how does it feel i mean that's the
house you know it's so interesting when
our house was contaminated
nobody cared about this house was only
things
uh we need to be get out as soon as it
was
realized it was polonium rather active
then uh we had just 20 minutes
to get out then as we stand across the
road from the house
a neighbor suddenly interrupts us
letter from hi what are you doing
she angrily tells us the lives of
residents have been turned upside down
since the attack and asks us to leave
can i say my kindness to you because i
came through exactly
the same my husband was killed in in
life i now recognize you i do apologize
and i feel for you exactly the two women
instantly seem to understand each other
and start talking united by a common
horror
two separate russia-linked poisonings
without justice just
lives ruined and a reminder that the
gray zone can affect
anyone at any time i've chosen not to
share the full exchange to respect the
neighbor's privacy
i was always saying just how i feel how
is a
people of local living here and just
ordinary people was just damaged
unbelievable and nobody understand it
because everybody
see it spy story everybody sees this
relationship between russia uk no it's
not about this it's about
lives of people we leave stopping
briefly to reflect
marina is visibly upset
oh it's awful isn't it yes i don't know
i i do understand it
absolutely oh
it's quite emotional really but it was
more emotional to meet
neighbors real people who met skripal
who called him friends when sergey and
julia skripal
left his house for the last time they'd
already been exposed to a deadly poison
they just didn't know it yet at around 1
30 that afternoon the pair drove into
the city centre
they parked and headed to a pub for a
drink then they went to zizi the pizza
restaurant for lunch
where they probably started to feel
unwell after eating
they walked a short distance to a small
park area
framed by the river aven it was here
the invisible nerve agent finally
overwhelmed the skripals
they collapsed on a park bench
surrounded by the otherwise ordinary
bustle of a sunday afternoon
a teenage girl out with her brother and
mother an army medic
was one of the first to notice something
was wrong and an ambulance was quickly
called
we're sitting in a place called the
maltings
in salisbury it's pretty much back to
normal you'd never know that this was
the scene of where
one of the most famous attacks on
british soil ended up with
the victims collapsed i would say maybe
not people
forget it but they want to forget it
because until you remember you can't
live
your normal ordinary life
but it don't need to be forgetted
because what we already said
without that it might happen again in
another very
quiet very peaceful place and
life others might be destroyed even lost
the quick action of medics helped to
save the lives of the skripals
the assassination attempt had failed but
the grey's own message
that you are not safe had still been
sent to
anyone viewed as a traitor by the
kremlin the message to the uk was also
clear
russia apparently still felt it could
get away with murder on british soil
12 years on from the killing of
alexander lipvinenko
to start with i don't think any of us
really quite appreciated what had
happened
mark saidwell or lord saidwell as he's
now known
was the uk's national security adviser
and top civil servant
until september 2020. if you think about
it
we didn't have a playbook or an
instruction manual
how to deal with people sitting in a
quiet park
in a quiet english country town
suffering a chemical weapons attack that
isn't something that you train
for because it had never happened before
and so the first responders realized
that this wasn't just
two people who'd had a seizure or who
who had some other kind of naturally
occurring uh problem but actually there
was something out of the ordinary here
and it was only uh after that and that
first response
um that then the information filtered
through to us at the
center that actually there was something
genuinely um
malign uh had happened and it was
completely extraordinary that uh that
some kind of nerve agent had been
deployed
as i said a quiet country uh country
town
and then of course your next question is
well who
and how and why the fallout from the
poisoning was only just beginning
a police officer detective sergeant nick
bailey
was left seriously ill after being
exposed to the nerve agent
when he went to investigate the skripal
house
fears of a deadly novichok trail
prompted police to cordon off
several contaminated sites then
four months later a local man charlie
rowley
happened across a discarded perfume
bottle thought to be the same one used
in the attack
and gave it to his girlfriend dawn
sturgis as a gift
they both fell critically ill and eight
days later
dawn sturgis became the first death from
this grayzone attack
the terror of the poisoning was combined
with what british analysts claim was a
significant
information operation by russia a study
by king's college london
counted 138 separate and often
contradictory narratives
published by the russian state channel
rt and news website sputnik
in the four weeks after the poisoning
coverage was gradual initially but
picked up significantly
after this statement to parliament by
then prime minister theresa may
on the 12th of march the government has
concluded that it is highly likely
that russia was responsible for the act
against sergey
and julia skripal mr speaker this
attempted murder
using a weapons-grade nerve agent in a
british town
was not just a crime against the
skripals
it was an indiscriminate and reckless
act against the united kingdom
putting the lives of innocent civilians
at risk
and we will not tolerate such a brazen
attempt to murder innocent civilians
on our soil i commend this statement to
the house
i asked mark sedwell what it was like to
deal simultaneously with the poisoning
and the disinformation did it feel to
say like reality you're like
starting to question yourself certainly
certainly you you we we questioned the
i think the underlying assumptions that
that there was there was a sort of
unspoken assumption really
that we all follow there are certain
rules even among adversaries certainly
state adversaries that we all understand
and this broke all of those rules this
was way the other side of them was the
first chemical weapons attack
in western europe in a century and the
first outside war time
so ever really and also going after a
spy that had been involved in a spy swap
exactly so he wasn't an obvious it
wasn't an obvious
target in the sense of a threat to the
to the russian state it was a revenge
attack of some
uh of some kind so we were trying to
deal with with all of that
um and then as you say
we had this information uh campaign
coming at us as well and i think the
thing that was different about that
and it took people some time to
appreciate
was that we weren't facing our narrative
the truth based on the evidence in the
investigation
versus a single alternative narrative
from
the russians the russians weren't
seeking to do that
because they knew in the end that any
single narrative they came up with was
going to be punctured because of course
it wasn't true so what they sought to do
was simply confuse
and so they put out dozens of different
narratives through lots of different
means social media
their official media spokesman
and so on really changing their story
contradicting themselves the king's
college study
found the most prominent set of
storylines in the russian coverage of
the skripal poisoning
tackled the response by the uk and its
allies
claiming that there was a lack of
evidence that moscow was to blame
like assassinations the deliberate
spreading of lies
or a distorted version of the truth to
so doubt
or to deceive is nothing new britain
used such tactics against the nazis
in the second world war including with
fake german radio stations
set up by a journalist called sefton
delma a fluent german speaker
[Music]
mr delmar said the aim of his first
station
called gustav siegfried eins was to
quote
spread disruptive and disturbing news
among the germans
which will induce them to distrust their
government and disobey it
this included bogus reports on nazi
corruption
and scandalous claims about military
wives having affairs
while their husbands were away fighting
fast forward
80 years and campaigns of disinformation
or black propaganda are still spread via
radio shows or innocent looking news
articles
the game changer is digital technology
and social media
it means fake news can be shared around
the world
to more people faster than ever before
you know the russians were putting 60
bits of major media out there
from the 4th of march hey de brushan
gordon is a chemical weapons expert
and former army colonel who also happens
to live near salisbury
he agrees to meet in the city centre i
think one thing
that the british government didn't
really and still i don't think
understand
is this business of you know the
the government's view is well we must
put stuff out that's
correct it takes 48 hours for clearance
of
of a line to come out in that time the
russians have put out 120 major pieces
people believe it i mean highly educated
people i know
sort of do from time to time say well
did we get this right and
even had a conversation with somebody
today saying guys is
did the salisbury thing really happen
wasn't it just set up and used to go
crikey
because they've had so much of this
[Music]
disinformation
had russia chosen to launch a missile on
sergey skripal's house
it would have been a clear act of war
that could well have justified a
conventional military response by the uk
but the alleged dispatching of deniable
hitmen
shrouded by waves of what the uk claimed
was state-backed disinformation
meant the british retaliation came from
the gray zone 2
and it started quickly mr speaker the
house will recall
that following the murder of mr
litvinenko the uk
expelled four diplomats under the vienna
convention
the united kingdom will now expel 23
russian diplomats who have been
identified as
undeclared intelligence officers they
have just
one week to leave russian president
vladimir putin denied the salisbury
allegations
while calling sergey skripal a traitor
to the motherland
and a scumbag
but less than two weeks after the attack
britain's spy agencies and the police
had gathered enough evidence to convince
allies across the
world to join in a mass expulsion of
russian spies as punishment
it was a clear sign the uk had learnt
lessons from the litvinenko
assassination
when it was seen as having been too slow
and too cautious in its response
mark said well again it was clear we had
to move faster
this time and that meant uh taking some
quite challenging decisions about
declassifying intelligence for use with
the public and in particular
with allies being ready to say look
yeah we haven't got all the details yet
in the early stages we haven't yet
collected all the evidence
but it was the russian state and we
called them out and there's no
alternative there's no plausible
alternative
the quick use of facts backed by
evidence is one of the most effective
ways to fight back
against disinformation in the gray zone
so we move very very quickly
to put together the diplomatic sanctions
the expulsions in particular of the
russian intelligence capabilities
military intelligence capabilities and
others
around europe and the uh and the rest of
the western uh democracies to try
and regain the initiative after an
attack of that kind and that's probably
one of the key lessons from salisbury
but not every ally joined in the mass
expulsion including
eu member state austria perhaps
sufficiently persuaded
by the russian information campaign what
did you think of that
look you're always frustrated of course
country some countries who for whom this
was hard
because of their interests with russia
and because their traditional
relationships
would look for opportunities
to slow things down and to find reasons
not to
take a difficult decision and we had to
factor that in
that some of the uh pressure back at us
if you like from
countries that were finding this hard
was well why do you have to go so fast
why can't you wait until the
investigation is
complete why can't you wait until you're
100 sure that it was then because
there might be there might be other
explanations
and of course the information campaign
that you referred to a minute ago was
part of
um that that was the audience that was
part of the audience it was designed to
influence it wasn't just trying to
influence citizens in this country but
it was trying to influence foreign
governments and create
confusion and doubt about the the
british
the british narrative and position the
kremlin retaliated with tit-for-tat
expulsions
and doubled down on its denials but
britain's response wasn't over
counter-terrorism police and
intelligence officers spent the next six
months building their case against
russia then
on the 5th of september uk prosecutors
charged two russian nationals with the
attempted murder of the skripals
and therefore appealing for anyone who
has information about the suspects named
by the crown prosecution
service today as alexander petrov and
ruslan
boshirov to contact the police both
suspects are approximately 40 years old
they are both russian nationals and they
were traveling
on russian passports it is likely that
they were traveling under aliases
and these are not their real names
images were shared
tracing the men's movements from their
arrival at gatwick airport on the 2nd of
march
to two trips to salisbury including on
the day of the poisoning
then mrs may stood up once again in
parliament
with a direct message for the gru we're
increasing our understanding of what the
gru is doing in our countries
shining a light on their activities
exposing their methods and sharing them
with our allies
just as we have done with salisbury
it triggered a bizarre response from
moscow with the two accused men
appearing on state-backed russian
television to protest their innocence in
person
what were you doing there
[Music]
our friends had suggested to us for
quite a long time that we visit this
wonderful city salisbury a wonderful
city
what makes it
throughout throughout europe
and the fact that it's famous
it's famous for its 123 meters
it's also famous for its clock it's one
of the oldest working clocks in the
world
journalism can wield great power in the
gray zone as a force for good
or for bad the skripal poisoning and the
evidence released by the police
offered up clues for a new breed of
investigative digital journalists to
follow
it really wasn't until the british
authorities published the names and the
photographs of the individuals involved
because before then there wasn't too
much for us to work on
elliot higgins is the founder of the
investigative website bellingcat
and what was it called bellingcat it was
a fable about a group of
mice who were very scared of a ferocious
cat and they came up with the idea of
putting a bell on its neck but they
realized they didn't actually have a
plan to do that
so we're teaching people how to build a
cat um then i googled bellanthecat.com
and that was four thousand dollars to
register
so i took that out and had banning cat
and it's forty dollars so i use that
he and his colleagues are experts in
analyzing online photographs
and trolling mass databases for tips
data and imagery can be vital to expose
the truth behind a grayzone attack
the bellingcat team was able to draw on
experience they'd gained
from tracking an alleged gru mission in
montenegro
in that operation from a couple of years
earlier russia was suspected of backing
a coup plot
previously one of our researchers
christo grozev had been looking into
gru russian intelligence activity
uh in relation to the montenegro coup um
there
um what happened is the one these
couples had been um arrested
he had two fake he had a fake identity
and a real identity
and there were similarities between them
like the date of birth his first name
and some other details
so christo thought well maybe this is
what we have with these uh
gre officers or suspected gru officers
in relation to the script poisoning
bellincat and its partners managed to
uncover the true identities of the two
men
accused by the uk of the poisonings
almost immediately as these names were
revealed
uh russian kind of independent media
matched to acquire
a list of people who were on the plane
including their passport numbers
this had the passport numbers of the two
suspects and funnily enough they're only
a few numbers different so that was
massively suspicious um so we're able to
and these documents had very weird
markings on them
um you know saying stuff like you know
this is you know not for you know
this is uh security service related and
if you see this document phone this
number that was like linked to the
russian ministry of defense
which is not on normal forms of this
type because everyone's supposed to fill
them in
like their history as well was just
completely blank in it so we found their
fake identity documents and how they
were registered which were very
suspicious
and we've eventually found their real
identity how can you give a sense of
how you managed to do that in one case
it was quite easy to do because
the guy had the same first name place of
birth
and date of birth and we basically
plugged that information into these
russian databases and it gave us a very
small selection of results
we then looked into each individual
because that then gave us addresses
second name and other details
and nearly all these individuals had
like an online presence so we could
identify who they were and then kind of
cross them off the list and eventually
just reduced it down to one individual
when we had that one individual we then
dug into all their other details and we
managed to acquire their real passports
and that showed exactly the same
photograph that was on their fake
passport the other guy though wasn't as
easy
um he um hadn't used the same first name
he hadn't used the same place as birth
but what we did there was thought okay
let's do a profile for this guy like a
criminal profile so we knew he was
around a certain age based on what he
looked like we knew that um on his
fake id he had an age on that so we
thought okay if he's a foreign operative
he was probably going to be working
uh or trained at a specialized academy
for the gru
so we basically looked at the graduates
from a certain period of time we started
going through the list of graduates and
eliminating them
eventually we reduced the list down to
quite a small number of people
and started finding you know photographs
of them online all of them were still gi
officers and went up and did different
things but
by doing this process of elimination it
took us down to one individual who again
were able to get the passport
restoration for and it was the guy's
photograph so we had two real identities
to these two fake
personas alexander petrov is actually
dr alexander mishkin a military doctor
in the gru
while ruslan boshirov's true identity is
colonel anatoly chapiga
another giu officer velenkat also
revealed evidence of a third suspect
though so far the uk's never formally
charged anyone else
a guy called dennis sergiov and he had
been traveling
around the same time we were able to
have a whistleblower at the russian
phone company who sent us his complete
phone records for two years including
the
period of the scripple poisoning and
that included every single
cell phone tower he connected to in
london and using that we could track his
movements basically from the airport all
the way through london
where his path crossed with the two
skripal suspects just before they got on
the train and went to salisbury
over time bellincat has gathered more
databases and information
on other alleged grayzone activities by
a whole team of giu officers
codenamed unit 29155 do you believe that
their sole intent is
assassinations or is it is it other
elements of sub threshold warfare
um from what we can see there's
assassinations that they're involved
with
um there's not sure that they're
involved with hacking we think that's
actually done by a separate unit
but they are involved with um organizing
coups um so it seems that they are
more on i guess even more the darker
side of this it's not hacking it's
assassinations and basically
overthrowing governments
and i mean what do you how do you
respond to the
um the sort of the allegations that are
thrown at bellingcat that
uh instead of revealing the truth you're
actually
you're part of the conspiracy or part
you know part of the british state and
you're being fed stuffed by mi6 and
cia and actually what you're revealing
is just
part of a gray zone-style attack on
russia
well um i mean belly cat came from
basically me starting a blog in 2012 and
then crowdfunding assigned 2014. so
uh if we're an intelligence operation
we're pretty poorly funded
as well as the very public criminal
charges and diplomatic expulsions
the uk is also thought to have hit back
in more covert ways
like quietly targeting illicit money
flows out of russia
in a further attempt to deter attacks
moscow still says it's unfairly accused
in the skripal poisoning
here's sky news's dermot myrnahan asking
the then russian ambassador to the uk
alexander yakovenko about the case it's
the coincidence of two
gru officers being sightseeing
in salisbury on the same day that's the
story of the
of the british press and also the
government but unfortunately it's not
supported by the fact
first of all they gave the injury in the
russian television
and they so said officially they are not
part of the gru
this is first and second uh the british
side
uh could have an opportunity to question
them
but they will never ask for that so
there's request from the foreign office
will allow them to be questioned
yeah we were ready to consider but the
request
never appeared there was no request
why well why do you think i don't know
i don't know no suspect has been tried
and there seems little chance of that
ever happening
it's left critics thinking the uk should
have gone even
further in its response to make the cost
of this kind of alleged activity by
moscow
so high it wouldn't be repeated
then two and a half years after
salisbury
this happened hi there good evening the
german government says hospital tests
show that the russian opposition leader
alexi navalny was poisoned by a nerve
agent from the novichok group that's the
same type of nerve agent
that was used to poison the former
russian spy sergei skripal
and his daughter julia in salisbury in
2018.
another victim of the nerve agent
novichok
unlike the skripals alexei navalny was
poisoned in russia
he was flown to germany where doctors
helped save his life
and uncovered how he'd fallen sick the
kremlin is again
under suspicion and again denying
involvement
the eu and the uk have imposed sanctions
on six russian officials
they claim were involved in the
poisoning this includes the current head
of the fsb
security service the successor agency
to the soviet era kgb
economic sanctions are another kind of
weapon used in the gray zone
but the risk is that they too fail to
deter
marina litvinenko is worried she thinks
if previous british governments had been
stronger in their response to the
killing of her husband in 2006
the attempt on the scripper's lives
wouldn't have been made either
it's a very similar because they tried
this with my husband sasha case
it was a lot of noise but it was okay
what you will do you will you will break
our relationship
no of course it was some breaking
communication between security service
they don't spend
a lot of secrets between each other but
people still able to come to this
country to buy what they want to send
their children
everything nothing change it's all the
same
but something is changing every time an
attack
like the skripal poisoning or the
litvinenko murder happens
it becomes a little less shocking
the acceptable level of violence for a
country like the uk
that's supposedly not at war climbs
just that bit higher the use of
disinformation
also creates doubt about who was to
blame
the frog to repeat graham lamb's phrase
is being boiled alive but hasn't yet
noticed
trust me what churchill said of our
journey inevitable in his eyes into
world war
ii was entirely preventable we can
prevent that
if we don't then the answer is enjoy the
gathering storm
because bad news is coming
disinformation has lots of
other uses too it's at the heart of an
unprecedented battle between truths and
lies
that's threatening democratic elections
across the world
information warfare goes on all the time
and i call it the 4d model which is
dismiss
distort distract and dismay but that's
next time
as we continue into the gray zone
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited
and produced by chris scott with
production support from sophia mcbride
and victoria seabrook
and narrated by me debra haynes the head
of sky news radio
is dave terrace and a special thanks to
lord ashcroft
for the use of his archive audio from
world war ii
[Music]
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts